[Music]
foreign you are watching The Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with the
editor of the voice newspaper Lester
Holloway and the Barrister and former
government Minister Anna subri so let's
see what's on some of those front pages
for you now well the star carries
allegations from this morning's former
resident doctor ranj Singh that he was
sidelined from the program by ITV bosses
when he raised concerns about its
behind-the-scenes culture
here's the mail their headline TV Doctor
hits out at toxic this morning
and the mirror leads with Philip
schofield's former co-presenter Holly
Willoughby saying she will remain on the
program
the express says Supermarket bosses
aren't convinced a cap on the price of
basic food items proposed by the
government would lower people's bills
that's also the main story for the eye
according to the guardian Metropolitan
Police Commissioner Mark Rowley is
poised to tell his officers they should
no longer attend mental health related
call outs
the Ft has a story from the US reporting
that many right-wing Republican
politicians are unhappy with house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy's decision to
reach an agreement with President Joe
Biden on raising the debt ceiling
and the times reports that police from
the National Crime agency will help
countries in North Africa to identify
and break up people smuggling gangs
a reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by Lester
Holloway and Anna subri welcome to you
both let's start by having a look at the
I newspaper and this story the headline
there Supermarket bosses hit back at
PM's plan to cap food prices and Anna um
explain this this cap on the food prices
Basic Essentials first of all
well I think this is it was an idea to
grab a headline probably in today's
Sunday papers that the government the
prime minister has said that they're
going to try to persuade the
supermarkets to enter into a voluntary
agreement whereby certain key essential
foodstuffs are capped now in my view
this is a as I say an attempt just to
get a nice easy headline but of course
now the detail or rather the opposition
and the reality of this idea is
unraveling and so the and it's not
supposed to supermarkets actually the
British retail Consortium I quite
rightly saying this is just not going to
work they make the point which I think
is a fair point that most supermarkets
actually are desperate to get customers
in by saying our prices are cheaper than
our opposition prices so they are
already slashing their prices they're
doing these Club card deals as well
um and of course any attempt to put a
have on food prices actually the reality
is they the people it hits are the
producers notably also the farmers and
in simple terms it doesn't work and now
the government finds themselves in a
position whereby a number of the papers
rightly are reporting the fact that what
sounds like a good idea is actually a
pretty rubbish idea Lester is it
essentially a good idea though to want
to cap the price of uh basic food
Essentials for the public
well
I think a lot of people will be crying
out for lower prices and although
obviously Anna was absolutely right that
the supermarkets themselves are are
trying to keep prices low uh because uh
they have bought in advance a lot of
their their produce and uh and food
stops
um it's taken a very long time for the
reduction in inflation uh to feed
through so if they were price caps then
it would be a temporary condition so it
would be a temporary hit
um on uh Supermarket but as Anna said
there is no uh price cap and we're in a
very strange situation where the
government is saying this is an entirely
voluntary scheme uh the supermarket the
retailers are actually saying it won't
work uh but we've got we've got
tomorrow's newspapers that are really
talking up at the idea that it is a real
uh price cap which you which the
government wants to impose which is is
clearly not the case at all but you know
the reason why uh you know food it
matters so much is because uh you know
it's going up at you know 20 so I know
uh the newspapers today are saying that
it's predicted to be around 15 inflation
on food but you know generally it's been
20 recently uh rents have been going up
uh 20 as well and inflation has only
just come down uh from double figures so
this is really unaffordable for many
people we've got three million people uh
that are using food uh truffle trust
food banks Alone
um so something needs to be done
um and uh you know we're clearly we're
not going to have a price count but as a
result our people are going to be
squeezed even more
yes and Anna as the express points to
the the price cap the supermarkets are
saying actually won't reduce food bills
um and that's what the the public need
and want
yes but it's not as simple as saying put
a price cap on and everybody whatever
your political views are whatever your
whether you're a supermarketer even the
consumer people who are desperate to see
prices go down because they're working
in food banks or they're campaigning
quite properly to alleviate poverty
everybody's saying this is not the way
to do it the Elite's not going to
achieve it now look we as Lester was
saying we we have five uh food inflation
running at somewhere in the region of 19
apparently tomorrow it might go down to
15 but it is still very high and it's
one of the highest in the world and what
we should be doing is looking at why
it's a particular problem in the United
Kingdom and is there anything that the
government can do uh not asking the
supermarkets you know keep setting this
is meant to be a voluntary scheme to cap
prices but looking at why our food bills
are going up in this incredibly High way
and the ft and other papers are looking
at analyzing that one of the reasons
only one reason is because we have left
a single Market because of brexit we
don't have the the free movement of all
those components that often go into food
and food production it hits food
production particularly hard when Goods
can't come in and out of the country as
they used to when we remember the
European Union there are other reasons
of well of course there's the war in
Ukraine the rise in energy and of course
we have the problem with wages that are
often going up but not in the same
proportion as food prices so it is
complex but it just seems that everybody
is saying this just looks like a cheap
headline the reality of it it's not
gonna it's not going to happen and it
isn't going to do that this isn't going
to solve the problem do the trick
yes many finding holes in the the price
Camp the idea that the price cap one
that it is a voluntary scheme Lester and
also what about those further down the
the chain the the farmers I mean what
happens to to their prices
yeah well absolutely and of course
that's the the six moves on the question
uh but I think sometimes this consensus
that price caps won't work uh is
something worth unpicking itself because
of France and has imposed a price cap on
staple foods so we've shown that you
know a major economy uh can can do that
um so if something worth considering
rather than just you know throwing a bad
idea about but uh you're absolutely
right Jillian that there is a question
about uh the food producers uh but as I
say uh you know this could be a
temporary uh measure because prices are
coming down but food prices will take a
long time to catch up with that and
perhaps we need to consider some
government uh intervention uh to the
sector uh in order to uh you know deal
with the these Rising food prices which
are simply unaffordable for so many
people
and Anna we read in the financial times
that also conservative MPS are very
critical of this uh price captain and
there's a a backlash within within the
party
yes I mean I'm not somebody who normally
agrees with people like uh John Redwood
or Ian Duncan Smith those are two of the
people quoted by the Ft as saying
actually if you're a free market
conservative what on Earth is a
conservative government doing getting
involved in the market and doing sort of
back in the back into the 70s idea of
putting caps on on prices and it is
quite extraordinary to hear this coming
from a conservative government but I
think it it shows that they know that
this is as Leicester rightly it
identifies this is hitting the lives of
real people and of course when food goes
up it disproportionately affects poorer
people because they suck they spend a
higher proportion of their um income
such as it is on the food so the
government recognizes all of this and
it's floundering around this isn't
really know what to do and he thinks a
price cap just it will get as I say a
cheap headline and I think it's
backfired
there so let's move on to the elections
in turkey and president erdogan has that
secured another five years the official
uh numbers and and votes come in in a
couple of days time but um that's
academic he has declared uh victory in
the elections in Turkey
uh yes he has I think that will
disappoint many people who uh dismayed
over the last few years but with uh over
ones increasing authoritarian
um Administration uh but he looks like
he's saying he's won against his Marvel
uh Kamal uh to which parole
um and and that's the situation that
we've actually got but the fact that it
was almost neck and neck
um I think he's actually a result of the
fact that inflation uh is is about 85 or
it was last October right strawberry
figures but also uh you know everyone
has been accused of uh you know a a
lackluster approach to uh the
earthquakes uh which uh have been uh
been felt in in Turkey as well uh but
what but interestingly uh the papers are
suggesting that the reason uh why uh
over one eventually won was because uh
between the first vote
um and the and the runoff which we've
just had the results of uh turnout
heavily in the big cities uh where the
opposition leader uh Terrell originally
had strong support
um and um and and provinces
um uh which uh supported other one their
uh turnout didn't uh drop um as much so
it would be interesting to find out why
that is now what really went on uh
between the first vote and the second
vote
yes and the opposition leader kilich
Terror glue is not actually officially
conceded uh defeat and one suspects that
um he's a slightly disillusioned and
we'll possibly have more to say on that
in the coming days but we're hearing
tonight that uh Wishy sunak has spoken
to president erdogan uh personally this
evening to congratulate him Anna
yes I mean that is the standard way that
leaders of countries conduct themselves
that whether you agree with the person
who's won the election you uh you ring
and you you congratulate them and macron
and others have done the same I mean it
is it is disturbing because of this
authoritarian streak in erdogan that
we've seen notably in recent years and
there have been all sorts of stories
about the way that his campaign has
effectively cut and prevented
um proper debate a proper discussion so
it doesn't bode well turkey faces many
difficulties and it is thought that
erdogan is is not going to meet those
challenges because his record would
indicate that he's not able to tonight
he said I respect her the result it's
not just me but it's turkey that has won
the winner is democracy the words from
president erdogan this evening Anna
Alessa thanks very much for the moment
we're going to take a break coming up
the guardian is reporting that the Met
police no longer intends to send office
says on mental health related call outs
we'll discuss that and more next
[Music]
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview still with me Lester Holloway
and Anna subri let's take a look at the
guardian and this story in which we read
that the Met police will no longer
attend emergency calls related to mental
health incidents take us into this story
Lester
uh yes this is uh comments from um the
max Police Commissioner um so Mark
Rowley uh who says that uh he wants to
um to not answer emergency mental health
calls uh he's calling with scheme uh
Life Care uh right person
um but I think that the the worry that
many people will will have uh is that
given the ambulances take so long to
arrive but up to 12 hours in some
instances uh when you've got a mental
health situation going on who is going
to arrive now there is a serious Point
um here in relation to the
appropriateness of police uh turning off
because sometimes they do do a good job
but other times they they don't uh
because sometimes police officers are
fixated but with uh whether a crime has
been committed as opposed to dealing
with the uh the the health aspects of it
now obviously police officers are not
trained and health workers but we've
seen some terrible those tragedy in the
past including the black community where
the light to Sean wig and Mikey Powell
and Roger Sylvester have died after
police have attended a mental health
emergency so it doesn't always work it
is more appropriate for health
professionals and and paramedics to deal
with these situations rather than the
police but as I say
um the uh the ambulance service is
extremely stretched at the moment so
what is going to happen if nobody turns
up Anna does this development worry you
oh yes for all the reasons that
leicester's identified and indeed the
report in the guardian as well look we
know we've got a I think we have a
crisis in mental health I mean we know
that certainly the the mental health
services that children in particular use
the waiting lists are utterly and
totally unacceptable now things have
improved in the time that I've been out
of the criminal justice system and
they've come back into it
um I I know that there are now often
mental health workers at police stations
and I think there's a better
understanding that often people do have
a a severe mental health problem and
they need treatment they don't mean
restraining and they don't need to be
treated like a criminal they need to be
seen as somebody who's not well but I
just don't think that there are enough
of those services and when there is an
emergency somebody has to attend and if
we don't have enough health workers with
the ability to attend there's nothing
wrong with the police going along
especially as they're not from
coordinate things and perhaps reassure
people members of the public who are
concerned have been frightened by some
somebody's Behavior because they're not
well so I I find this a very disturbing
development so we've got about a minute
to talk about the story in the front
page of the mail and this is the Saga at
this morning it's turned down a
different avenue now and being accused
of a toxic culture
uh yes that's right uh the uh the
medical uh pundit uh on the program this
morning uh ran soon uh is is on uh many
front pages including of the mail saying
that uh um he blew the whistle on the
toxic culture uh that there is there so
so this is really about
um you know the story clearly you know
is uh about Phillip Schofield is you
know upset and appalled a lot of people
and so the story has legs and they're
finding a way of the newspapers of
trying to move it on it has to be said
that uh Iran Singh himself said that he
had no knowledge
um of the the affair uh that um Phillip
Schofield had
um so uh it's just really about the the
toxic environment within the program
which I have to say is Not Unusual
obviously I'm been knocking around at
the media for for a little bit let's
stand there are many programs which
which have a toxic environment